[Musique]
bonjour qui sans jacob bonjour après
plus d'un mois de grève contre la
réforme des retraites des transports
reprennent une activité normale pour le
plus grand soulagement de milliers de
français qui ont sont allés travailler
par tous les moyens
durant cette période la lutte continue
les syndicats prononce la phase rite la
phrase rituelle des fans conflit à la
fois pour rassurer leurs adhérents et
garder la face pas de révolution mais
une révolte qui gronde toujours à
travers un pays inquiet méfiant
christian jacob c'est votre première
longue intervention depuis votre
élection à la tête de l air par les 58
militants de 58 militants de votre parti
58 mille militants de votre parti qui
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ne remplirait pas
le stade de france vous nous direz
comment vous comptez à nouveau attirer
les adhérents verts un parti classique
fidèle de jacques chirac
depuis que d'être passé du syndicalisme
agricole à la politique vous voulez
porter aujourd'hui les valeurs on dirait
un nez au chiraquisme
vous avez toujours répété à ce titre et
deux principes de ce que vous appelez de
règlement intérieur du gaullisme article
le chef dirige
article 2 en cas de problème se référer
à l'article mais en réalité vous êtes
quand même un adepte du travail
collectif est votre ambition pour 2022
et de préparer le terrain pour une
personne qui pourra effacer le souvenir
de l'humiliation de 2017 pour interroger
avec moi cécile cornudet des échos et
damien fleurot de ces news mais avant
cela on va écouter et regarder le
présent la république c'était après
l'intrusion de la cfdt
toute forme de violence j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à l'égard d'élus
les violences à l'égard de syndicalistes
quel que soit d'ailleurs les
confédérations syndicales sont une honte
pour notre démocratie est inacceptable
des intrusions christian jacob à la cfdt
au théâtre des bouffes du nord où
étaient emmanuel macron comment vous
qualifier ce climat social est ce qui
vous inquiète est ce qu il se radicalise
oui climat social est inquiétant le pays
en tension comme il l'a comme il l'a
rarement rarement été personne ne peut
cautionner des actes de violence d
intrusion par là par la force ou
ailleurs en france toutes les
revendications à partir du moment où ils
atteignent pas les fondamentaux de notre
république peuvent être légitimes
peuvent s'exprimer doivent s'exprimer
mais elles peuvent pas le faire par là
dans la violence en même temps le trafic
revient la ratp on l'a dit c'est pas ça
que vous choisissez de retenir que
finalement on touche à la fin de ce
mouvement social contre les retraites
écoutez c'est une bonne nouvelle que
l'ec raismes arrête les franciliens
puissent puissent circuler et là
l'ensemble des français mais ça n'est ça
n'efface pas effectivement la forte
tension que que l'on ressent partout et
de ce point de vue moi si je partage
l'avis du président de la république
pour pour sanctionner les actes les
actes violents
on voit bien qu'il ya un exercice du
pouvoir qui est anxiogène et mais oui
mais alors juste avec l'euro - christian
jacob
on a vu le ministre de la culture a dit
qu'il était contraint obligé d'annuler
sa cérémonie de voeux qui devait se
tenir ce lundi
la bibliothèque nationale de france à
paris parce qu'il y à des annonces de
perturbation de manifestations est ce
qu'on est face à un gouvernement
empêcher
je sais pas si on est face à un
gouvernement en empêcher ceci étant le
gouvernement porte une responsabilité
dans cette dans cette tension permanente
il ya une certaine forme d'arrogance de
mépris de l'exercice du pouvoir
on l'a senti à différents moments au
tout début du quinquennat lorsque le
président de la république vous souvenez
notre dame des landes
il annonce cependant ça pendant toute sa
campagne qu'il prendre en compte
l'expression populaire les décisions
prises par les collectivités
territoriales or première décision qui
est prise ça a été de tout céder et tout
lâcher nouveaux voyous et les laïcs en
sorte c'était aussi après le méprise
s'est exercé à d'autres à d'autres
niveaux premiers textes moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'a marqué pour un
président de la république le premier
texte qui est présenté à l'assemblée
nationale c'est lourde de signification
le premier tech de nicolas sarkozy
c'était la loi tepa qui permet tait qui
a permis la défiscalisation et
l'exonération de charges sociales
il faut les heures les heures
supplémentaires avec le bouclier fiscal
l'a promis le premier texte présenté par
françois hollande a été de décrit
détricoter cette mesure mais par
conviction politique bronze
on est à l'opposé de ses convictions
mais il la détricoter le premier texte
d' emmanuel macron m les les élus
désignés les élus à la vindicte
populaire
c'était sa transe je continue vous savez
tout cela est révélateur
lorsqu'il s'en prend aux élus de la
nation souvenez vous de monsieur darmana
avec le balancent leurs balances ton
maire là aussi c'est du mépris lorsqu'à
la semble sur un débat obsolète malgré
l'acte 2 vous voulez dire un débat comme
celui des retraites
ben là aujourd'hui on les vit
aujourd'hui pour la première fois le
parlement sur un budget le budget des
retraites c'est 300 milliards d'euros
c'est 15% du produit intérieur brut de
la nation on va avoir le débat sans
parler du budget c'est à dire qu'on
court circuite l'assemblée nationale la
sent les effets en parallèle la
discussion est classé en éteignant ne
serait pas du tout en parallèle puisque
le débat va être le texte va être
présentée deuxième quinzaine de février
et la conférence finances bon je sais
pas ce qu'elle donnera et les pour le
mois d'avril
donc c'est de les intégrer
les mesures vont être réintégrés les
parlementaires les députés vont débattre
d'une soi disant réforme sans avoir d'
appât de dévaluation budgétaire sans
parler du financement elle leur dit
c'est pas grave on fera des essais
construits seront d'abord on a compris
que vous dites que le pays reste en
colère malgré la fin des grèves et
peut-être des négociations n'était pas
un terrain socio qui vont avancer mais
pour comprendre qu'est ce que va faire
et l'air à la donc à l'assemblée
nationale pendant le débat sur la
réforme des retraites
cette réforme vous la voter ou pas
attendez on sait pas c'est pas à prendre
ou à laisser il ya un débat l'assemblée
nationale passé avec ce site la
représentation des fameux les fameux
régimes spéciaux que la droite combat
depuis des années ont disparu vous
devriez n'en attendez vous devriez vous
avez vu ou qu'ils avaient disparu ils
sont avec nous nous avons été depuis le
début
force de proposition et les réformes des
retraites
ils ont été menés à chaque fois par la
droite avec des réformes tout à fait
important donc notre position elle est
très clair nous allons être force de
proposition dans ce débat si vous ne
m'aimez caltech vous parlez si vous
continuez la bla au fond l'opposition
qu'à mener qu'à mener les syndicats
jusqu'à présent ou fond vous faites en
sorte que une réforme passe nous on
souhaite une réforme passe et nous
sommes les seuls à avoir mis une
proposition très clair sur la table qui
est l'allongement permettait juste
quelques quelques instants l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation sur l'est la
réforme l'équilibré budgétaire des
retraites c'est simple c'est une
équation à trois entrées soit vous
baisser les pensions des retraités
c'est ce qu'a fait monsieur macron avec
l'augmentation de la csg soit vous
augmenter les cotisations de ceux qui
travaillent
c'est ce qu'avait fait le gouvernement
de françois hollande nous nous sommes
pour une autre voie qui est celle de
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
c'est pour ça que nous sommes pour une
mesure claire qui soit le report de
l'âge légal
ensuite nous sommes favorables à la
suppression l'étalement dans le temps
sur une douzaine d'années de la sortie
des régimes spéciaux
ensuite troisième pilier
la prise en compte d'une approche
sociale c'est à dire la prise en compte
de la pénibilité la possibilité de
réduire l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite pour ceux qui ont des travaux
difficiles et pénibles basées non mais
vous continuez d'un mois encore
elles m'ont encore si vous me le
permettez aux gouvernants là sur la
pénibilité
ces deux il ya des métiers qui sont
pénibles aujourd'hui ça n'est pas lié à
un statut c'est lié à l'exercice d'une
profession et donc notre idée est simple
c'est de dire eh bien par année
d'exercice de travail difficiles
lorsqu'on a vous avez fait cinq ans de
métier pénible
vous gagnez une année de bonus limitée à
4 ans qui trouve à singapour si on est
allé sur un âge de départ légal à la
retraite à 64 ans de pouvoir partir à 60
ans pour le mettre en confiance est en
train de se construire parce que dans
l'accord qu'il ya eu avec la cfdt la
cfdt reconnaît désormais qu'il faut un
mage et qu'il faut une mesure d'âge
qu'il faut un équilibre budgétaire dans
ce texte dont ça s'est quand même une
avancée d'avoir réussi à obtenir ça je
suis mdt que l'assemblée nationale qui
décide c'est dire notre équipe de la
possible
à partir du moment où des mesures on
arrive à un report de l'âge légal ce que
nous souhaitons nous n'a pas d'états
d'âme pour vous ne vous seriez d'accord
pour mener si on reporte l'âge légal
effectivement avec le temps d'y voir une
mesure d'impact par exemple avant
devaient savoir quelles sont les
conséquences budgétaires c'est normal et
que cette conférence financière qui sera
après le texte se traduisent pas par une
baisse des pensions supplémentaires ou
par une augmentation des cotisations
sera pas garantie de quoi dans les
mauves à couy mais la garantie c'est un
texte voté que vous faites quand toute
la nécessité de voter en même temps de
travailler sur le budget et sur les
mesures donc nous nous sommes sur les
trois les trois registres à la fois le
report de l'âge légal la sortie des
régimes jusqu'ici avec la cfdt pour
essayer de construire quelque chose
autour de l'équilibré
vous pensez que c'est une erreur qu'a
fait le gouvernement de décès de
construire quelque chose d'un classique
ou fait confiance aux partenaires
sociaux qui vont oui négocier pour
trouver la mesure des niveaux
mais pour le moment de négociations il
n'y en a pas eu la réalité on part d'un
mensonge qui est aussi celui de
l'élection présidentielle encore une
fois lorsque le président de la
république dit pendant la campagne des
présidentielles il n'y aura pas de
mesures d'âge prévisions 1 du corps vous
le savez bien était pas les mêmes à ce
moment là tout à fait c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous avions passé de
60 à 62 ans et vous avez dit regretter
le président de la république annonce
qu'il n'y aura pas de mesures d'âge les
gens l'entendent et donc après
effectivement ça crée des tensions quand
on leur dit maintenant c'est pour ça que
nous nous avons tout fait sens où nous
attend mais nous avons toujours assumé
une vraie mesure d'argent or l'âge pivot
ce n'est pas une mesure d'âge
c'est une belle et nation gassion c'est
une baisse de tension bon nous vous
savez on n'a pas de n'a jamais eu de
difficultés pour voter un texte
lorsqu'il il va dans le bon sens et qui
correspond à nous attendre dans une
reine dans une attitude qui consistera
aussi à faire en sorte que l'objectif
face avec des propositions d'un second
faire si votre électorat on va reparler
soutient cette réforme on en reparle oui
ou non de voix
à condition qu'elle soit fait dans la
transparence or aujourd'hui
chaque jour qui passe on est davantage
dans le flou rappelez-vous ce qu'ils
avaient annoncé la sortie des régimes
spéciaux chaque jour qui passe il ya un
régime en novembre à 20h40 qui a annoncé
en pleine préparation donc pour les
municipales et avec une sécu ne circule
air du miz de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui vous énerve beaucoup alors
cette circulaire on va prendre le temps
d'expliquer parce qu'elle est quand même
importante elle faire relever donc le
demande aux préfets de relever le seuil
des mers classé sans étiquette passant
donc 2000 à 9000 habitants lors d'un
déplacement d'ailleurs en seine et marne
on va d'abord l'écouter
la présidente du fn marine le pen donc
cible christophe castaner alors je les
dis je pense que cette circulaire est
une minable manipulation minable et
grossière l'objectif est évidemment de
gonfler artificiellement les scores de
son mouvement
et c'est une c'est un acte d'opacité
christian jacob quelles conséquences
pour vous on n'arrête pas de vous
entendre dire que l'élection municipale
c'est d'abord une élection de maire sans
étiquette début qui forme des races en
trans partisan du mans le temps de le
dire souvent honnêtement à la séquence
que c'est qu'est ce que c'est que cette
circulaire est pourquoi vous ne voulez
nous a fait un scandale
d'abord c'est de changer les règles
des dévaluations des résultats deux mois
avant les élections municipales de se
concentrer uniquement encore une fois
sur la france des villes
seule la france des villes présentent un
intérêt pour le président de la
république
en dessous ça n'a pas d'importance et
puis surtout on veut pas on veut pas
regarder de trop près mais là c'est
quand même un changement de règle qui
est on ne peut plus on peut plus
choquant en plus de ça avec un système
qui qui permettra en réalité dès qu'une
commune aura reçu non pas une
investiture mais le soutien de la
république en marche elle sera classé
immédiatement divers centres quelle que
soit l'étiquette donc c'est le message
politique on appelle qui a été fait mais
c'était pas aimé voir de l'association
des maires de france pardon avait
présidé par françois baroin c'est bien
pense pas je vais pas du tout entendu
comme ça sur le ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui par tard monsieur castaner
ce qui est d'autant plus choquant c'est
vraiment de choisir l'intérêt partisan
c'est à dire de son parti politique de
la république en marche au détriment de
l'intérêt général quel problème ça pose
d'avoir un enfant sage politique c'est à
dire d'avoir un éclairage sur les choix
politiques de nos concitoyens sur
l'ensemble des territoires de france
mais encore une fois qu'on se concentre
sur les villes le reste n'a pas
d'importance et on va même jusqu'à
considérer les villes en fonction du
fait qu'elles sont chefs lieux
d'arrondissement ou passez vous prenez
deux villes identique de 8500 habitants
l'une est chef lieu d'arrondissement
l'autre ne l'est pas alors l'une sera
retenue dans les messages politiques
claude matin qu'est ce que vous dénoncez
les combines les combiner le choix d'un
ministre de l'intérieur qui choisit le
l'intérêt de son propre parti politique
c'est à dire une petite combine
politicienne au détriment de l'intérêt
général personne ne remettait en cause
cette circulaire qui posait pas de
problème majeur alors à près de dire
c'est pas mille que ce soit 1500 ou 2000
peut-être que ça aurait sa chance
d'accrocher les décrets saint-jacques
déposer un recours
d'ailleurs j'ai vu que déjà un certain
nombre d'élus locaux avaient déposé des
recours et nous nous allons le déposer
déposer également pour contester
plusieurs choses tout d'abord le fait
tel que j'allais de l'évoquer à
l'instant qu'on ne va considérer en
nuances âge politique que les villes
eq les les zones rurales ne compte pas
et n'ont aucune importance
ensuite il ya un vrai problème juridique
puisque vous êtes sur une circulaire qui
modifie un décret ce qui pose quand même
là aussi pour pour le moins un point de
droit d'apporter dans leurs cours ils
arrivent tard ça fait ça fait presque
deux mois que la circulaire n'est pas
encore publiée normalement vous savez
comme moi que pour pouvoir déposer un
recours il faut que la circulaire soit
publié c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé au ministre de
l'intérieur qu'elle soit publique cette
circulaire pour qu'on puisse déposer
leurs recours mais là c'est vous n'avez
jamais utilisé les ciseaux pour
redécouper les cartes électorales il y
amène des spécialistes dans votre
famille politique mais aussi jason
strictement rien à voir vous faites
allusion à quoi peut doivent redécoupage
de la carte est d'accord mais là on
n'est pas sûr du redécoupage de la carte
électorale
là on est sur le fait de dire on prendra
sur un plan politique en compte le vote
de nos concitoyens six habitants ville
en revanche en zone rurale ça n'a aucune
espèce d'importance ça n'intéresse pas
le gouvernement parce que la république
en marche a peur d'avoir de faire un
mauvais résultat national je pense je
pense que ça largement guidé le choix du
ministre de l'intérieur et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous dis il fait
ce fait ce choix qui est quand même
assez surréaliste pour a misé d'intérêt
à deux - à deux mois des élections
municipales plaidé quand même pour la
cohérence politique mais c'est pas
toujours facile donc à suivre
du côté de l air parce que des merdes
oncle républicains seront soutenus par
la république au marché là ça vous pose
aucun problème ou même avoir d'ailleurs
des marcheurs sur leur liste alors vous
allez laisser faire vous savez combien
de maires les républicains vont être
soutenus par la république en marche
dites-nous 6 sur les villes de plus de
30 milles sur 300 communes
mais et c'est là là là la théorie du
porte bagages que j'ai dénoncé c'est à
dire quand la république en marche
c'était bien souvent le cas et dans
l'incapacité de présenter des listes
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'ancrage territorial parce qu'ils n'ont
pas d'élus qui soit suffisamment
représentatifs ils se précipitent pour
dire coucou on est là et on soutient et
le font pour nous mais le font aussi
pour d'autres d'autres familles
politiques parce que en réalité ils
n'ont pas cet ancrage
il nous faut ce lien avec le territoire
des féroé
et dans le cadre d'autres alliances
c'est à dire des élus de votre famille
politique qui viendraient chercher le
soutien du rassemblement national
quelle est votre attitude est ce que
vous laisser une liberté à ses élus elle
a toujours été sans ambiguïté tous les
dirigeants de la feuille politique qui
m'ont précédé qu'ils se soient appelés
jacques chirac nicolas sarkozy jean
françois copé laurent wauquiez il ya une
étanchéité totale avec le front national
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
exclusion de ceux qui soutiendraient liu
qui prendrait sur leur lit pour le
moment ça concerne 1 un cadre du
mouvement dans la ville de sefrou valeur
voilà c'est celui de lunel et sète
qu'est ce que vous vouliez a également
les gangs de cette zone euro qui sert il
de cette année 22 7 que l'on qui a
consisté à la semaine dernière à
l'archet mais il s'agira durant
cinquante huit mille militants luiz mais
sur le plan du principe justement vous
dit
à chaque fois que l'on ira parce qu'il y
aura cette tentation sûrement 1,2 pour
pouvoir rassembler dans une vision pour
le moment c'est à dire quoi bon parce
qu'il ya deux communes pour 35000
commune donc ne veut pas dire que ce
soit sur le banc on continue sur les
municipales cécile cornudet oui il ya un
dernier sondage à paris qu'il est se
profiler un match hidalgo bâti comment
vous l'analysez c'est le retour du
clivage gauche droite à paris c'est
d'abord une très belle campagne de
rachida dati
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la seule
possibilité pour les pour les parisiens
de créer une vraie alternance à anne
hidalgo c'est rachida dati c'est elle
qui incarne à l'alternance avec une
progression de campagne très forte
je vous rappelle qu'au mois de septembre
octobre a été crédité de 14% en
quatrième position et le score de
nathalie kosciusko morizet en 2014
c'était plus de 30% et aujourd'hui et le
score d'anne hidalgo étaient 34 il est
de 24 donc si vous voulez qu'on rende
dans les chiffres on peut on peut dire
dont rim et je vais je vais pourquoi il
ya cette dynamique autour de rachida
dati
il ya bien entendu sa personnalité son
tempérament que les français connaissent
bien mais c'est surtout parce qu'elle a
un vrai projet d'alternance
il ya un vrai projet pour les parisiens
sur les sujets de la sécurité de la
propreté des transports delà de la
mobilité du logement il y a un projet
qui est présenté et moi j'appelle tous
les parisiens qui en ont assez
effectivement de la manière dont la vie
il est géré par les socialistes et par
anne hidalgo de se rassembler autour de
refouler rien compris les électeurs de
basri niveau surtout ceux qui souffrent
tous les trois on s'adresse à tous les
parisiens
les électeurs de rivaux ils sont de
moins en moins nombreux c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire puisque à chaque
sondage qui passe et dégringole c'est la
spirale infernale dans ce qui était le
temple de la macro ni on voit qu'à paris
effectivement le maquereau nice mais en
train de partir en fumée
christian jacob vous le vous raconter
finalement chez normal un peu la belle
histoire mais il ya aussi de la
stratégie et des problèmes liés à chaque
arrondissement
est ce que vous allez imposer des
candidats les républicains dans des
arrondissements où déjà se trouve des
élus de droite comme par exemple le 15e
avec philippe goujon qui lui veut être
soutenus aussi par la république en
marche quand vous allez faire nous les
choses sont très claires
rachida dati est celle qui aujourd'hui
incarne ce projet pour paris et
l'alternance possible à la gauche il
faut que dans tous les arrondissements
de paris
les parisiens aient la possibilité de
voter pour rachida dati est pour et pour
les républicains
parce que le système électoral
aujourd'hui à paris ce que nos auditeurs
doivent ni à comprendre est différent
des autres systèmes électoraux
on ne vote pas il ya le système paris
chaque arrondissement
voilà il ya une élection dans chaque
arrondissement et donc il faut que ces
élections se fassent dans la clarté
ce qui veut dire qu'il faut que dans
chacun de nos arrondissements et bien
les parisiens et l'assurance en votant
pour une liste que ce sera des gens qui
apporteront leur soutien à rachida dati
c'est ce qui est fait dans tous les
arrondissements il nous reste
effectivement un arrondissement a
tranché sur le quinzième mois je demande
de la transparence
nous avons demandé à toutes nos têtes de
listes qu'ils soient tous bas qui
s'engage clairement auprès des parisiens
en disant voilà si vous votez pour moi
si je suis conseiller de paris voilà
pour qui je voterai comme maire pour ce
puisque vous demander des engagements on
le monde
on va vous poser la question aussi
concernant une autre ville donc à
perpignan où la louis aliot donc du r n
est en passe peut-être de l'emporter est
ce que vous participerez au front
républicain qui s'organise pour faire
barrage à lou aliot à perpignan
mais aujourd'hui les pas question de
faire barrage à louis aliot il est
question de faire de faire gagner notre
équipe municipale parce que cce
aujourd'hui nous sommes sortant et moi
je suis très confiant sur le fait que
nous allons gagner à perpignan c'est
toujours une élection difficile
perpignan salle sera encore mais nous
gagnerons
on se pose pour la suite vous y rendre
et oui je me rendrai la droite va-t-elle
sortir de sa retraite forcée avec ce
nouveau président on l'a dit tout à
l'heure vous avez été élu par 58 mille
militants une fois de plus ça ne remplit
pas un stade complet ou vous lancer une
campagne de recrutement quand vous allez
faire on travaille d'abord sur sur cette
élection c 130 mille militants qui
étaient invités me il y avait cinquante
huit mille militants à jour de
cotisation vous avez raison de le
rappeler sur le reste vous savez tout
d'abord on travaille dans le collectif
vous l'avez vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure ce collectif a permis d'apaiser
les choses il y avait des tensions
internes indiscutable je pense que
aujourd'hui tout cela est apaisé
maintenant nous sommes dans une deuxième
phase c'est celle du travail de fond
après trois défaites successives
présidentielle législative européenne
un peu d'humilité ne nuit pas et il faut
reprendre les choses sur le terrain
beaucoup de proximité beaucoup de
travail de fond d'où ce forum qui vont
être lancés là dans les quinze jours
dans les quinze jours qui viennent qui
vont qui rassemble à la fois des
parlementaires des élus territoriaux des
gens de la société civile de 80 experts
qui viennent à la fois de la haute
administration qui viennent du tissu
associatif qui viennent du monde de
l'entreprise militer voeckler fait
également son corps nu pour bien
travailler le fond peut-être qu'il faut
avoir une ligne claire et c'est vrai que
sur les retraites on n'a pas forcément
comprise vous l'avez expliqué tout à
l'heure on sentait que vous guettier les
reculs du gouvernement pour dire que
emmanuel macron n'était plus réformateur
ce qui vous positionnez-vous
dans le camp un peu libérale en dernier
ces dernières semaines nous avait
rectifié le tir en parlant de pénibilité
bon c'était où exactement la ligne c'est
quoi la ligne en train guillaume
pelletier qui mise sur la hausse d'une
cellule alors c'est là effectivement
bruno retailleau qui n'est pas là qui
lui est plus sûr la chose publique
c'est ça tout le monde sait quoi bonne
ligne le cap que vous fixé pour que ces
travaux de vaud convention soit
fructueux c'est le travail
alors ça c'est une vraie référence de
droite et sur les retraites
j'y reviens d'un mot sur les retraites
nous nous sommes accrochés à la valeur
travail et on considère que pour
équilibrer notre système de retraites il
faut aujourd'hui travailler plus
longtemps et n'ont pas augmenté le coût
du travail en augmentant les cotisations
comme l'a fait la gauche ou baisser les
pensions des retraités c'est à dire
baisser le pouvoir d'achat mais mes
attentes et ainsi pouvoir d'achat
version paitier baisse des dépenses
version retailleau économiquement c'est
quoi votre ligne les deux sont
totalement liés
c'est à dire quand je parle de la valeur
travail c'est de redonner de la
compétition des trains positions
antagonistes sur le plan de la politique
économique absolument pas absolument pas
tant des plafonnements la démonstration
et seize noms y compris non l'état on a
besoin s'agit pas d'augmenter le smic
s'agit d'augmenter les salaires ce qui
est différent
vous avez une nécessité de la baisse de
la dépense publique nous sommes les
seuls à voir à l'occasion du budget
faire des propositions très claires avec
eric woerth sur la baisse de la dépense
publique
aucun autre parti politique à commencer
par celui au pouvoir n'était capable de
le mettre sur la table
nous l'avons mis sur la table donc il
faut baisser la dépense publique pour
pouvoir redonner de la compétitivité et
c'est comme ça qu'on peut alléger les
charges des entreprises parce que dire
aujourd'hui qu'on allège les charges des
entreprises sion ne baisse pas dépenses
publiques c'est mentir comme quand le
gouvernement nous explique que l'on
baisse des impôts mais c'est un mensonge
éhonté la réalité d'ailleurs le cdh
vient de classer la france comme la
championne du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires jamais les prélèvements
obligatoires n'ont été aussi élevés
qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui
le taux d'imposition des entreprises est
le plus élevé loyalistes jacob qu'on
vous écoute quand attentivement ce sont
toujours les mêmes mots de la droite
près
negar fiscalité vous allez pouvoir
parler d'autre chose damien fleurot mais
attendait peut-être une question mais
peut-être que ça vous gêne
simplement nous ne nous gênons mais le
passé le passé plaide pour nous lorsque
nous sommes engagés à baisser les
dépenses publiques nous les avons baissé
nous avons baisser la dépense publique
nicolas sarkozy l'avait fait avec le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
ça a été une réalité
emmanuel macron s'y était engagé vous
savez le résultat depuis deux ans les
dépenses publiques augmentent de 30%
plus qu'elle n'augmente s ou françois
hollande est reconnaissant à françois
hollande que lui il s'était engagé
publication jacob sur le thème nouveau
pour la droite vous dites on arrive
enfin on s'en occupe on vous entend pas
on nous a pas entendus depuis le début
de cette émission sur un sujet pourtant
capital l'environnement la lutte contre
le réseau journée en impose et le mal et
la ligne là aussi de votre partie parce
que ces dernières années elle a beaucoup
fluctué
non on est sur une approche qui est
autour du développement durable c'est à
dire avec une logique d'entreprise qui
repose sur un trépied le trépied c'est
le suivant c'est d'abord la rentabilité
économique une entreprise ne tient pas
s'il n'y a pas de rentabilité économique
le deuxième élément du trépied c'est un
facteur de progrès social
il faut que ceux qui travaillent
bénéficient de cela d'où la nécessité
d'augmenter effectivement les revenus
liés au travail par rapport à la 600 et
3 s'assurer du respect de
l'environnement c'est à dire non pas
avec une écologie punitive mais avec une
écologie qui soit un signe d'un fait
confiance à la convention citoyenne qui
est organisée par le citoyen sévir au
sort mais elle peut tout à fait apporter
une contribution simplement moi je pense
qu'il y ait un certain nombre de leviers
dont on doit se saisir notamment sur les
carburants
l'utilisation des biocarburants dans le
secteur agricole qui était aujourd'hui
oubliées or on voit bien qu'on a là à la
fois des possibilités en termes de
performances performance énergétique
performance économique et respect de
2 de l'environnement on a aussi des
possibilités que nous avions fait au
moment de l'élection des heureux des
élections européennes pardon d'avoir une
frontière écologique c'est-à-dire de
taxer les produits d'importation qui
rendent avec des coûts carbone très
élevé ce sont des propositions très
concrètes et nous allons les reprendre
que de quelle manière nous travaillons
sur les six mois qui viennent d'où ce
forum que l'on met en place trois
conventions qui vont se tenir
une première qui va se tenir sur le
sujet du handicap
une deuxième qui va être sur le secteur
de l'autorité autorités c'est aussi un
marqueur très fort de la droite
monsieur péchenard qui est là qui est
qu'avec tous frédéric péchenard qui
qu'il incarne
quand en tant que vice-président de
notre famille politique et un troisième
3ème convention qui va qui va être sur
le pouvoir sur le pouvoir d'achat
ensuite nous allons avoir le congrès des
idées aux mois de juillet et après nous
attaquons sur trois hôtels notamment sur
celui de sur celui de l'environnement
qui sera un thème de l'automne en propre
aux autorités fessée cornudet wiman une
macro et son gouvernement ont changé de
ton sur la question des violences
policières
est-ce qu'ils ont eu raison est ce qu'il
ya eu des excès comment vous aborder
cette question
alors écoutez ça je pense qu'il ya des
enquêtes qui ont été ouvertes et qui le
kilo qui le diront ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il ya une pression énorme qui
est mise sur les forces de police et les
forces de sécurité
est ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur
ce côté anxiogène du pouvoir on a cédé
aux voyous et aux casseurs aux débuts
fait qu'aujourd'hui l'époque les forces
de police ont sollicité comme et l'ont
jamais d est donc conséquente lie à
cette pression il peut y avoir des
dérapages qui sont nés ils sont
immédiatement qui sont condamnables sans
ambiguïté lorsqu'il y en a simplement
les enquêtes sont en cours donc
attendons d'avoir les résultats ne se
trouvait que les forces de police sont
bien défendus par leurs ministres mais
les forces de police sont d'abord
d'abord elles défendent bien les
français c'est ça leur mission et ils le
font avec beaucoup de professionnalisme
beaucoup d'engagement mais mesurer la
pression qui est la leur la manière dont
ils sont sollicités
et effectivement si li à dérapages qu'il
doit être condamné
la valeur les armes rien à revoir sur
l'utilisation des armes ou sur les
méthodes les plaquages au sol par
exemple écouter peut-être que vous êtes
un expert dans ce domaine je ne suis pas
moi je fais confiance à ceux liés à ceux
qui le sont pour savoir si effectivement
ces armes sont les meilleurs j'ai plutôt
le sentiment que oui j'ai le sentiment
d'une efficacité quand on regarde ce qui
se passe en maintien de l'ordre dans
d'autres pays
en plus on peut plutôt être fiers du
maintien de l'ordre en france une
manifestation aujourd'hui se tient
contre de la gpa organisée notamment par
une partie de la droite celle qu'on
avait baptisé à l'époque la droite
trocadéro à nouveau dans la rue
le texte au sénat vous évoluez sur sur
ce sujet sur ce texte est ce que là
aussi l air mute change s'adapte à
l'époque où on reste sur des tenants
plutôt conservateur sur le vote sur la
pma pour toutes
moi je me suis opposé j'ai voté contre
et j'assume mon vote content parce que
je pense que de fait on ouvrira à la gpa
pour tout et je considère qu'il y a il
ya des risques importants dans ce dans
ce domaine
c'est donc la raison pour laquelle en
conscient je me suis opposé j'y reste
j'y reste opposée mais j'étais à
l'époque président d'un groupe
parlementaire j'ai laissé la liberté de
vote parce que je considère que sur des
sujets comme celui là chacun en fonction
de ses convictions intimes et
personnelles doit pouvoir s'exprimer et
on a veillé à faire en sorte que quelles
que soient les convictions des uns et
des autres chacun dans un groupe
parlementaire puisse s'exprimer
vous travaillez donc un projet nouveau
on l'a bien compris avec des experts
avec votre votre collectivité c'est vrai
que vous mettez vous mettez en place une
nouvelle méthode
ce projet il sera porté obligatoirement
par la personne qui sera désignée pour
porter vos couleurs en 2022 ou comme
d'habitude il sera rangé dans le tiroir
en dix ans le candidat ou la candidate a
son propre projet n'a jamais été rangé
dans le tiroir ya toujours eu un travail
de fond qui a était qui était utile moi
ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment ce travail collectif
encore une fois on doit tirer les
enseignements
de nos trois défaites successives et
donc on va pas sortir des mesures ne
s'est pas collectif avance bien
finalement ce n'est pas collé que je
vous dise que nous sommes en train de
faire donc de faire un travail collectif
je ne crois pas aux mesures qui sortent
d'un chapeau je pense au travail de fond
c'est la raison pour laquelle douze
forum un premier congrès des idées en
juillet il y en aura un deuxième en
décembre ou en janvier 2021 et un
troisième qui se tiendra en juillet en
juillet 21
et puis au moment de l'élection de
l'élection présidentielle et bien ce
projet aux candidats bien voilà il ya
plus qu'à appliquer non mais il y aura
une belle base et y aura beau travail de
fond qui aura permis de positionner à la
fois notre famille politique mais plus
largement que que cela l'ensemble des
français nous ouvrons tous ses forums
encore une fois à la société civile à
différents acteurs qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas nécessairement engagé
politiquement mais nous avons besoin de
faire ce de faire ce travail j'y crois
beaucoup et ce sera une belle base et à
bord un beau fond pour notre candidat à
la présidence labour qui à l'issue du
séminaire gouvernemental mercredi le
chef du gouvernement edouard philippe a
détaillé la feuille de route de
l'exécutif et a annoncé d'ailleurs un
plan contre le radicalisme et la lutte
contre le communautarisme on écoute on
regarde nous travaillons à un plan de
lutte contre l'islam radical et contre
les communautarismes d'ici le mois de
mars
le président annoncera le plan d'action
sur ce sujet prioritaire pour l'unité et
la concorde nationale
vous craignez de voir passer des villes
aux mains des islamistes en mars 2020 le
risque existe toujours c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle on collègue
bruno retailleau a déposé une
proposition de loi au sénat et que nous
reprenons nous reprendrons dans un
groupe parlementaire à l'assemblée
j'espère que là la majorité nous nous
suivra dans un livre récent françois
pupponi maire de sarcelles justement
dénonce la décortique un peu le système
des communautaristes dans dans les
villes notamment en région parisienne
vous êtes conscient alerte oui
c'est l'arrêt nous sommes la seule
chaîne en politique qui a déposé une
proposition de loi
et alors ce qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous allez faire d'autre m'a écouté à
part cela sas a déjà beaucoup mais mais
au delà de au delà de cela c'est un
sujet que nous avons toujours pris à
bras le corps ce qui n'est pas le cas je
le rappelle d'une gouvernance que
j'entends les annonces du premier
ministre et moi je suis ravie si ça si
ça se passe simplement c'est à peu près
tous les trois mois où les quatre mois
avec monsieur macron nous annonce un
discours et des grandes mesures sur le
sujet et quand le président de la
république dit le voile dans l'espace
public ça n'est pas mon problème mais
c'est d'une irresponsabilité en arabe
lourde si jacques chirac s'était
comporté de la même façon en 2003 la loi
sur l'interdiction du voile à l'école
qui a été prise d'ailleurs à
l'initiative de françois baroin n'aurait
pas été votée si en 2010 jean françois
copé et nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas fait
voter la loi sur l'interdiction de la
burqa on en serait où c'est à dire que
si jacques chirac et nicolas sarkozy
s'étaient s'était comporté comme
emmanuel marc connan serait en disant
que mais ça n'est pas mon problème
alors moi j'espère que c'est le problème
du président j'ai toujours du mal à nous
nous sommes dans l'opposition et nous
apporterons nos contributions
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs le conseil
français du culte musulman le cfcm
renouvelle ses instances il avait tenté
d'être réorganisée également par nicolas
sarkozy la présence de ce qu'on appelle
l'islam consulaires des représentants
donc deux des pays étrangers pour
l'islam est encore très forte
l'islam de france est une chimère en
fait moi je suis effectivement choqué
par cela je pense que nos amis musulmans
doivent avoir cette capacité à
s'organiser et ne pas dépendre de nation
de nations étrangères mais mais au-delà
de ça il ya vous savez il y a aussi les
des individus qui aujourd'hui sont
fichés sont signalés au fichier de
prévention contre la radicalisation en
vue d'actes terroristes et à peu près
vingt mille personnes qui sont fichés
sur ces vingt mille personnes
il y en a à peu près 4000 qui sont des
étrangers qu'est ce que ces étrangers
fiche est de cette manière font encore
sur le territoire national c'est de la
responsabilité directe du gouvernement
le président de la république tant qu'on
est dans les discours
va bien mais maintenant qu'ils passent
au soft vous entendez attendait
justement 17 ans et demi qui nous
annonce des grandes mesures mais qui les
prennent vous voulez qu'ils s'expriment
vous demandez ce qui s'exprime
publiquement et c'est pas qu'ils
s'expriment ça il s'exprime
régulièrement mais simplement qu'ils
présentent un projet de loi qui lie à
une discussion qu'il y ait des décisions
de prises aucune décision deux sont
prises dans ce domaine aucune d'ailleurs
floraux cette semaine christian jacob
on a eu le droit à deux déclarations de
candidature pour 2022 celle de ségolène
royal et puis celle de marine le pen une
confirmation et j'imagine que vous
n'êtes pas étonné et dans votre famille
politique vous vous y mettez aussi les
deux personnes sentiment que j'avais un
peu peur de l'oubli non le procès qu'il
nous a motivés marine le pen vous avez
l'impression que son parti je pense
qu'elle se dit que c'est plutôt leur des
élus locaux et qu'un risque de de passer
à la de passer à la trappe
et donc elle avait envie de faire un
petit coucou j'existe bon c'est l'heure
n'est pas aujourd'hui à l'élection
présidentielle la préoccupation des
français ça n'est pas ça aujourd'hui
c'est d'aller mieux
c'est d'avoir un système de retraite qui
soit équilibrée c'est d'avoir une
revalorisation une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat d'avoir davantage de
sécurité mais d'avoir des mesures
concrètes pour lutter contre lui et ça
n'est pas dans la préoccupation des
français
savoir qui sera candidat à la
présidentielle dans deux ans et demi ce
que j'aime en l'occurrence quand on est
lui à la tête d'un parti comme le vôtre
on n'est pas totalement la procuration
des français on également 5ème
république n'ont fait autour de la
taille vous occupez et que vous pouvez
pas à la fois toujours dire la 5e un
public est 5ème république et ne pas
reconnaître que c'est l'élection
structure la seule la plus importante
dont avec la question c'est comment vous
vous y préparer est-ce que vous avez
déjà entendu une fois dire le contraire
justement parlons-en berne où l'on
réparé le rendez vous il est d'ors deux
ans et demi on citera on s'y prépare
avec un travail de fond quand on a trois
défaites électorales de successives
comme je le disais tout à l'heure un peu
d'humilité du travail de fond et on sera
prêt le moment venu elle n'est pas venue
aujourd'hui la préoccupation des
français
et quand on fait de la politique au sens
noble des choses et bien c'est de
travailler aux préoccupations
quotidiennes des français
or la préoccupation quotidienne des
français aujourd'hui ça n'est pas de
savoir qui sera candidat dans deux ans
l'élection présidentielle c'est quand
même faire en sorte que votre parti
redevienne un parti où on est mais ça
les élections municipales en des à ça ça
se joue aux élections municipales qui
auront lieu elle dans deux mois et là on
est dans le coeur des préoccupations des
français
comment vont être géré leur territoire
ça ça les préoccupe et nous travaillons
dessus la présidentielle ces agressions
d'accord à ce micro même la semaine
dernière gérard larcher président du
sénat disait il faut désigner notre
candidat par une primaire est ce que
vous êtes d'accord
je suis pas favorable à la primaire je
les dis et redis et je souhaite que nous
trouvions la bonne solution
en travaillant là aussi ensemble dans le
cadre du duduk au lait sont des autres
modes de désignation possible peut on
imaginer autant que autant que l'on veut
mais alors mais le vote des militants je
ne dors lésions atr de notre parti a
toujours été plutôt de désigner celui
qui incarne qui est le plus fort qui au
sommet qui est le premier vous allez la
présidentielle s'est effectivement ça
c'est là le rendez vous entre un
candidat et le peuple c'est sale et les
fondamentaux de la vème république et
moi je ne suis pas favorable à la
primaire pour une raison simple c'est
que la primaire cristallise les
oppositions sein d'une même famille
politique
et donc quand on chauffe les uns les
autres et et après à deux mois de
l'élection présidentielle alors dit
maintenant vous allez vous rassembler
pour être tous ensemble non je pense
qu'on a le temps d'y travailler mais
aussi de le faire encore une fois dans
un esprit collectif et on trouvera
croyez moi sans difficulté à la fois le
moyen de désigner ou le moyen de faire
émerger ce n'est pas désignée dans la
flore ou willy à une figure politique
vous l'avez citer françois baroin le
meilleur aujourd'hui selon vous à vos
yeux on connaît votre amitié votre
fidélité
au delà des liens d'amitié
depuis très longtemps avec avec françois
barois jeux pan il fait partie
évidemment des personnalités qui
aujourd'hui ont à la fois l'expérience
la compétence l'euro la notoriété et les
qualités pour le faire mais après c'est
une décision personnelle et on n'est pas
dans ce moment de cette décision
personnelle dans soyez patients oui
alors impatients même temps on entend
des choses qui est son raconter un peu
autour de vous c'est bien une sorte de
pacte entre vous deux au moment où vous
réfléchissiez à prendre le parti
j'y vais si tu verras la présidentielle
c'est ce que raconte en tout cas nos
confrères de l'express
est ce que vous demandez après en avoir
mais c'est pour ça qu'on pose la
question est ce que vous vous demandez
au fond à françois baroin de se décider
vite de manière à ce qu'ils si jamais il
décide de ne pas courir concours et pour
la présidentielle que d'autres puissent
se préparer il le dira le tout le moment
venu et je lui fais une totale confiance
vous ça vous dérange pas d'attendre
comme ça que je suis déjà parce que
avant le choix des personnes travaillons
sur le fond en proximité avec les
français et c'est cela le travail que
nous sommes en train de faire vous savez
si on veut faire passer les personnes
avant le reste on n'y arrive pas donc on
a besoin d'avoir ce travail qui est
légitime qui est sérieux et nous le
faisons en tout cas dans cet esprit de
rassemblement et de sérieux et
naturellement émergera notre candidat le
moment venu mais la vf l'euro mais
christian jacob quel regard vous portez
sur le travail que peuvent effectuer
d'autres personnalités qui se sont mises
en retrait de votre famille politique
valérie pécresse et xavier bertrand pour
les les cités est ce que vous estimez
qu'ils sont encore dans votre famille
politique qu'il pourrait revenir
notamment au moment de se désigner leur
est ressorti à votre parti peut-être que
je trouve d'abord ce sont deux
présidents de région qui font très bien
leur travail
valérie pécresse moi je suis je suis je
suis franciliens et il se trouve que
c'est une excellente présidente de
deux régions et je peux vous dire que
dans un département comme le mien et
notamment dans la partie rurale de la
seine et marne
eh bien on a vu le changement lorsqu'on
est passé du socialisme à la majorité
actuelle à la région peut être fier de
notre région donc il n'ya pas de départ
définitif et de non retour mais on n'est
pas dans le choix de la présidentielle
donc aujourd'hui sur deux personnalités
qui ont fait le choix de se retirer de
notre famille politique je le regrette
je n'ai pas toujours compris pourquoi et
notamment sur le choix de valérie
pécresse
mais c était son choix à un moment donné
vous allez parler d'eux et bertrand
quesada ont choisi pour les deux
personnes avec génie pour les deux donc
quand vous me parlez de xavier bertrand
et de valérie pécresse et je vous dis
les deux j'ai le sentiment de parler
aussi de levier bertrand pour 2022 on
entend beaucoup aussi attentifs à
oublier pour 2022 on entend beaucoup
en cas de match
maquereau le pen on n'ira pas voter on
en a assez de cette pression de ce match
imposée le chaos moi ça vous inquiète
ça correspond pour vous un vrai
mouvement c'est la société
c'est ce match il est organisé par le
président de la république lui dire
maintenant c'est qu'il sait si marino
celle cesser le chaos moi je pense que
la personne et les français ont raison
de s'inquiéter de cela on ne peut pas se
réduire à la seule alternative d'avoir
monsieur macron madame madame le pen et
c'est pour cela moi je crois vraiment à
la capacité pour la droite de revenir
effectivement dans le giron et d'être en
situation de pouvoir gouverner dans deux
ans et demi et je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
là-dessus parce que ce travail nous
sommes en train de le faire et il
portera ses fruits
merci c'était le grand rendez-vous de
christian jacob vous pourrez retrouver
en podcast à dimanche